[Musique]
les élections cantonales et régionales
ne provoque guère la passion des
citoyens français alors c'est peut-être
pour réveiller leur ardeur que le
candidat communiste à lille a présenté
une affiches provocantes et grossière
marianne masse dominique maes un poing
levé sur fond d' usine avec un message
sans équivoque c'est le cri de colère
qu'a voulu porter ce jeune candidat aux
cantonales à lille pour réveiller une
campagne somnolente et remobiliser sur
les luttes sociales on s'adresse donc
aux gens aux salariés qui sont jetés
comme des comme comme des kleenex après
avoir été utilisé on s'adresse à ceux
qui en ont marre de ce qui se passe en
ce moment et qui a envie de mettre un
coup de pied à
l'establishment quoi aux institutions
qui servent à rien la fiche est une
initiative personnelle de fabien roussel
et ne fait pas partie de la compagne
officielle du parti communiste
tiré à 1000 exemplaires elle s'arrache
déjà comme un collector et fait réagir
l'info dire quand même c'est la presse
qui on parle c'est la presse n'en
parlait pas ça s'arrêterait complètement
inaperçue le problème c'est que les gens
sont tellement détacher de la politique
que faut bien les mobilisé d'une manière
ou d'une autre avec quelque chose
susceptible de les faire réagir
mes arguments sont peut-être plus polis
ou plus policé mais le but est le même à
savoir que le peuple de gauche se
réveillent et qu'il vote qu'ils votent
fortement dans ces élections cantonales
et régionales mobiliser les
abstentionnistes c'est aussi le message
à droite mais pas à n'importe quel prix
à ce rythme là la politique va devenir
difficile à vivre si chacun affiche qui
en mer de l'autre qui virent on peut
multiplier comme ça l'est les petit mot
les petites villes garit et je crains
que ce soit vraiment pas une grande
chose pour la démocratie en tout cas la
fiche aura au moins le mérite de faire
parler dans le landerneau politique
lillois parce que les électeurs n'ont
pas l'air de l'avoir encore remarquer
[Musique]